Scot Osterweil: But Elinor is a
postdoc at University of
Liverpool in media studies. And
one of the things just by way of
introduction, one of the things
that I was interested to sort of
observe as I came to MIT,
comparative Media Studies, not
as a media scholar, but as a
practitioner, was all the ways
in which the field here
certainly at MIT was rooted in
the work of sort of
communications engineers. that
that that that many of the roots
of some of media studies were in
the work actually, of engineers.
And I've particularly think
about that in the way that the
concept of signal and noise
which is so relevant, our work
sort of had its origins in that
field. And what's so intriguing
about elders book, to me at
least is the ways in which she's
quite quite a scholars have
meaning someone.
Anyway, the ways in which media
scholars have tended to focus on
signal on the signal. And so
she's taken an interest in her
work, she's taking an
interesting look at the noise.
And the other thing that I've
struck by Elinor in your, in
your work is the focus on sound
as, as a metaphor, we frequently
the ways in which we use
metaphors around seeing, and
you're suggesting that we use
more metaphors around town, so.
So I'm really intrigued to hear
what you what you have to say,
I'm sure everyone else here is
too. So with that, I will simply
hand the floor over to you. So
Elinor Carmi: great. So thank
you very much, Scott, I'm going
to do the share screening parts
before we start. Um, so thank
you very much for this
introduction. And as you said,
the timing of this book was
perfect for the apocalypse. And
I had my ugly cry share of you
know, not being able to actually
come to Boston. But thank you so
much for giving me this
opportunity to present to you
and I'm really looking forward
for the date. I have kind of
like an hour and a bit more, but
I will try to shorten the
presentation so that you can
have more questions. And I'll
just start so Hi, everybody, and
I'm gonna do a talk about my new
book, media distortions. And you
can download a book, it's open
access, and you even have a
playlist with dark motives and
things like that. And you can
see things that didn't come into
the book. So please go into that
website. A bit about me, I like
to go to Comic Con, as you see
here, I thought that it would be
suitable to show you how I
always think about different
kind of bots and different kind
of deviant things. I'm, I'm a
researcher, activist, feminist.
And currently, I'm working on
several projects, which sort of
continue what I'm going to talk
about today around data
literacies. I'm going to talk
about that a bit more towards
the end of the talk. But I also
want to talk about my
background, I used to be a radio
broadcaster of psychedelic
trance I used to edit television
channels, is to be a journalist
of electronic jazz music
culture, and write about that.
And I wrote a book my previous
book was with the Israeli
psychedelic trance culture. So
for me, sound has always been a
way to think and examine things
through. So I think this is
quite important into sort of
introduction of this book,
origin story, if you may. So why
focus on the deviant us, um,
which is, I think, something
that, for me, I always was very
attracted to that. So even if
you think about the Israeli
psychedelic trans culture, that
was a culture that was sort of
deviant in the Israeli culture.
And I was always intrigued with
how different kinds of things
get categorized as deviant. So
for me, part of the part of the
power of examining things that
are a bit in the outskirts, a
bit called deviant is to really
understand the politics of
drawing these kind of boundaries
of what is deviant and by
understanding what is the
deviant we can understand what
is the norm much better So we
can in my book, and in my
research, I always try to
understand who created these
kind of categories of what is
legitimate and what is
illegitimate. Why and with what
transgression led do that, who
does this category serve? And
how do these categories affect
the way that we engage with
media and technology? I also
questioned what is a media
phenomenon. So when I started my
PhD, which this book is based
on, a lot of people said, Oh,
but this is, you know, this is
marketing, or this is
advertising, or this is computer
science. And actually, people
thought, Oh, you know, we know
what is spam, it's like emails
about Viagra and Nigerian
princes. And for me, one of the
main maybe points to take from
my book is to question these
kind of things that we take for
granted. Whether it is different
kind of terms of think, or a
different kind of definitions of
things. As media scholars, I
think it's really important for
us to not take for granted what
computer scientists tell us that
things are, but also what you
know, marketers or advertisers
tell us things are. So this was
kind of my standpoint. And also,
of course, to examine these kind
of boring things, or these kind
of things that are common sense
or taking for granted.
So in the book, I look at I
examine a three case studies,
I'm going to focus on one today.
But I encourage you to read the
book, and you'll see all the
others. And what is really
important for me is that when
we're talking about these kind
of deviant media categories
there, they keep on changing and
evolving. So I focus on noise
and the early 20th centuries of
Bell Telephone as one of the
biggest media company of the
time, and how they sort of
structure different kind of
territories, and people's
behavior. Then I focus on spam,
which isn't the sort of the end
of the 90s and early 2000s. And
then I focus on Facebook, and
how they categorize anti social
behavior. So what is important
for me to say is that I think
some of the problems for us as
media scholars is that the sort
of that our media, our research
objects keep on changing very
fast. And I think one of the
things to take from from these
kind of things is the bigger
questions, right? Like, we're
probably some of us are doing
research on Facebook, which
hopefully wouldn't exist in a
decade, but what do we actually
take for the questions that we
want to ask within Facebook. And
this is something that is also
very important for me to to
emphasize that media is gonna
come and go, but the kind of
larger questions of how
different kind of categories
shape our behavior is something
that's really important for me
to examine. So, in a nutshell,
my book is about media power.
However, most of the times when
we think about media power, and
most of the sort of the theories
that we have around it, and
especially when we talk about
the internet, of but also it's
like the internet is, you know,
we just take them Michel
Foucault's panopticon, which
uses very visual concepts about
what we can see and what we can
see it but also, what's really
important about the panopticon
is architecture has a huge
element in this kind of media
power theory. We also have a lot
of different kinds of terms.
When we talk about these things.
We talk about vision and
visibility when we talk about
algorithms, or AI and different
kind of things like that. And of
course, let's not forget Frank
Pasquale is a book about the
black box. And what I sort of
sort of realized as I was
examining my research, and if
you see I just now I almost said
I saw it. So it's kind of a
crazy how ingrained this kind of
visual concepts are, in our
terminology, and how we think
and how we explain different
kind of things. So when I was
writing the book, I had to
change different kind of words
into sound concepts that made me
realize how ingrained it is and
how we think and engage with it.
So one of the symptoms, these
are the kind of things that I
felt that are missing within the
visual frameworks, which is,
when we're talking about these
kind of power relations between
media companies, we're talking
about multiplicities. We're
talking about multiple actors,
multiple spaces, multiple time,
multiple purposes of conducting
listenings and rhythms, which
I'm going to talk about shortly,
and different kind of
architectures. So what vision
doesn't really allow us is to
sort of go between the
boundaries of spaces and usually
when I do this kind of talk, I
do this kind of experiment where
I show that, you know, if I'm
going to shout, it's going to
pass the walls, but my vision is
kind of constrained within time
and space. So my, the
theoretical approach that I
developed is influenced by
multiple other approaches, such
as media theory, and you're
going to talk about it a bit
later in the science and
technology studies, software
studies, feministic Oh, science,
critical Legal Studies and force
sound studies. And it's really
important for me to emphasize
that I used grounded theory,
which means that I didn't really
assume that I know all these
things in advance. And it's sort
of these kind of things came up
as I was examining the material
that I was doing research on. So
these are the kind of Sonic
epistemologies and I'm going to
come back to that a bit later.
And for the people who are
reading my book, and maybe
notice each chapter, each of the
share of the case studies is
divided. The first half of the
book is dedicated to the service
structuring of territory, which
is the media, and then the
second part to the process
listening. So what I, what I'm
trying to say with these things,
is that I am taking a different
kind of approaches. And I'm
showing how power relations are
constructed with these two
concepts, which I'm going to
talk about shortly.
And I'm going to start with the
first one process listening.
When we're talking about Science
and Technology, most of what
we're talking about knowledge
production, we usually we
usually hear about theories that
use vision concepts. However,
there are sound theories to
happen using sound as a way to
sort of understand and to
produce knowledge. So one of the
main sort of theories that has
been produced was by Alexandra
Supper and Karin Bijsterveld
from the Netherlands, and
they're talking about different
kinds of practitioners who
produce knowledge. So for
example, doctors, when they
listen to you with a
stethoscope, or car mechanics,
listen to the car, and how they
make date different kinds of
diagnosis, in order to
understand what's happening with
different kind of bodies. So
they make this kind of
classification of different
kinds of modes of listening, and
how these kind of practitioners
make their assumption and then
make different kinds of claims
with our bodies healthy, or is
it malfunction or different
kinds of things like that, what
I noticed when we're talking
about the online environment or
a mediated environment, these
kind of modes of listening are
not enough, because we engage
with different kind of
environment. Therefore, I
developed a new mode of
listening, which is called
processed listening. It is a
mode of listening or by
practitioners, you can come from
different kinds of professions
and interests, listen to
different kinds of sources, with
different kinds of tools in
different times in order to
produce different kind of
knowledges. And by knowledges, I
mean different kinds of
profiles. So for example, when
Facebook listens to our behavior
through a different kind of
cookies and pixels, it creates a
different kind of profile on us.
And then they can rearrange the
platform in different ways to
make interventions in our tempo
special experience. And this is
what I mean by Earth media. Now,
when I was talking about when I
was trying to examine how
different kind of media
companies shape the way the
different kind of information is
flowing or not, I realized that
people use different kind of
concept like flow data streams,
data traffic, and channeling.
And what I realize is that these
concepts don't really explain to
you the politics, behind how
different kinds of information
or different kind of connection
is made possible or unpossible.
To us. And so, I was very
influenced by as I said before,
a different kind of media
theorist, especially Raymond
Williams, and his concept of
plant flow. I was also
influenced by feminist
technoscience by their notion of
process. And of course, Henri
Lefebvre a rhythm analysis. And
basically what all of the
combined concepts are saying is
that when all of these
companies, whether it's
Facebook, or I'm going to
shortly talk about the online
advertising industry, when they
listen to you through different
kind of instruments in order to
create the profile, they then
create different kind of
architectures that are changing
according to that profile. So
the way that we engage with
platforms have a different kind
of ordering rhythm, which is
influenced by different kind of
political decisions that are
usually influenced by
advertising logic, and
obviously, money. So I like for
example, if I'm a doctor, and I
listened to your body in one
session, and that event has a
beginning and an end, when
different kind of platforms or
you know, web and online
advertisers Listen to me There
isn't a beginning or end to for
example, if Facebook listens to
me, it's not like Oh, now I know
everything there is to know
about Elinor by the 22nd of
October 2020. And I don't need
to listen to her behavior
anymore, is there is an ongoing
process of listening to my
behavior in order to have a
richer profile. And then this
profile is then helping these
kind of companies to create
different kind of architectures
that are arranged in a specific
way to make me engage more or to
make me click on a specific ad,
or to make me maybe sort of
comment on different kind of
inflammatory posts and things
like that.
So with with media, what I'm
trying to say is that it the way
that media companies reorder
different kind of components in
a way that orchestrates desired
rhythm. So they with this kind
of ordering, they decide what is
sociality, well filtering out
problematic rhythms, which they
defined as either noise or spam
or anti social behavior. So
these kind of practitioners they
conduct the way that mediated
architectures change according
to the knowledge that they
gained from process listening to
people's bodies across multiple
spaces. Now, if this sounds a
bit confusing, then don't worry,
I'm going to give I'm going to
go into the one of my case
studies. Now. So I'm in the end
of the 1990s. And and I just
want to say that I decided to,
it's really hard to know when
you write a book, and you want
to talk about everything, and
you can, you know, you don't
really know what to decide to
focus on, I really wanted to
focus on the standardization of
web metrics, which is the end of
the 1990s and the beginning of
2000s. Because I think that
everything that we experienced
today, around profiling around
fake news around disinformation
and misinformation, and
basically, the problematic and
broken online ecosystem where we
are the product started in those
times. So I think a lot of the
times, you know, people talk
only about the last decade, but
we're talking about processes
that happened probably 20 years
and probably even before, but I
think it's really important to
identify key moments where these
kind of things, which is
basically the surveillance of
our online behavior have become
normalized. And so in this case
study, I'm basically looking at
how did the standardization of
web metrics, which means how to
measure different kind of
behaviors in order to trade them
in an efficient way. So as you
can see here, of IAB, which is
the Interactive Advertising
Bureau, I wanted to standardize
different kind of metrics.
Because in those times, if you
remember, the internet wasn't
really, the web wasn't really a
technology that which was a sort
of that people knew that it's
going to succeed. So a lot of
the time we take for granted
that the internet is succeeding,
but actually, in those times,
that the kind of subscription
model didn't quite work. And
with the dotcom, bubble crash,
people didn't really know what
to do. And therefore different
kind of company specific
companies managed to survive
the.com bubble crash, including
Amazon, and then different kind
of platforms started to emerge,
which gave a free service.
Whereas, you know, as we all
know, it wasn't quite free, but
we were the product. So let's
see what happened in those days.
So this kind of the IB wanted to
actually understand how can we
standardize different kind of
measuring units? How can we
standardize how we measure
people's behavior in order to
make this kind of product? which
is our behavior as efficient as
possible? Because if we are the
product, then the kind of the
currency needs to be agreed upon
with all of the actors that are
involved. Does you can see here,
these were the most sort of
common
metrics.
And what they basically wanted
to understand is, how are they
going to measure it through
different kind of angles? Will
it be through the ad serving?
Will it be through people's
computer, and what will actually
count as a click what will count
as a total visit, and what will
count as an ad impression? Now,
for me, one of the most
interesting thing that was part
of this research was to actually
analyze different kind of
internet standards through the
IETF, which is the Internet
Engineering Task Force. And
also, I analyze different kind
of legal documents in order to
understand how do they actually
decide what's happening there.
So when I was starting to read
the cookie standard, which is
what you're looking at here, I
started to realize that
actually, what's happening in
the backend is that when you
visit a website, you through
different kinds of default
settings, you are being sent a
lot of cookies, which could be
dozens of cookies could be
hundreds of cookies, in order to
basically send different kind of
information. About your
behavior, if it's from the
website that you type on, that
would be first party cookies. So
that means that, you know, if,
for example, I look at The
Guardian, then it will be a
first party cookie that the
Guardian collects information on
me. But if it's third party
cookies, it could be ad
exchanges, or different kind of
data brokers, who are also gonna
sort of listen to my behavior
across different kind of
platforms, and throughout time.
So what I basically saw here is
that there is a standard, and
we're actually not really aware
of what's happening. What was
really interesting with the
standard, is that the people who
suggested it at the beginning
said, Well, actually, maybe we
will show part of the standard
will be to show people what's
happening in the back end,
because people don't really
understand that all of these
these things are happening. And
advertising industry at that
time said, No, no, it's going to
confuse people. So let's just
show them, you know, that the
front end, as computer
scientists call it, so that it
wouldn't confuse them to see
what's happening in the back
end. Um, but actually, when we
think about cookies, and one of
the things that struck me is
that all of the people who are
talking about cookies, whether
it's computer scientists, or
even media scholars, because
just a text file, but this just
a text file is actually a
communication form, is what
cookies actually do, is to print
different kind of text files.
But every time that you make
these kind of whether I'm
reading an article, or I'm
clicking on things, these kind
of things are communicated to
different kind of entities. And
those can be either, as I said,
before the Guardian if it's
first party cookies, or it could
be other data brokers, or
different kind of agencies,
which we are not aware of. So
this is what I was talking about
sort of knowledge not going into
the common sense, or the common
way of defining different
things. This is one of these
moments where I realized that
actually, you know, we've been
sold that cookies are just text
file, this is also part of a
legislation that's going on
behind it. But actually, it's a
form of communication, because
they're communicating different
kinds of topics, which could be
my gender, the kind of device
that I'm using, the kind of a
broadband that I'm using, and
different kinds of things
throughout time.
So one of the other things that
the advertising industry wanted
to do was because there was all
of these kind of robotic
behavior, they wanted to
understand who is human and who
is not human, because it was
really important for them, if
we're the product, it's
important to have exact
measurements. So what they did
was to develop this different
kind of made measurements, and
what they call filtration, and
filter, who's human, and who is
not human in order to make
accurate measurements of what is
happening so that they can treat
us. So as you can see here, they
develop different guides. So for
example, the base basic method,
which was a text file of robots,
the other one was identification
of specific suspicious or non
human activity, which was a
different kind of lists that you
were supposed to send the IAB.
And another thing was to analyze
the rhythms of users activity,
which I found really
interesting, because what they
were basically defining there is
what are the kind of behaviors
that are can be considered as
your bodek? And hence non human?
And what are the kind of
behaviors that can be defined as
humans? And as you can see here,
these are the kind of
definitions that they had of
what is the robotic behavior,
the sort of what did they
analyze in order to establish
that, so they establish what
users performing multiple
sequential activities, users
with highest levels of
activities, users who acted in
consistent interaction
attributes, and other suspicious
activities. And so what they
would do with that is basically
not only to try to understand
and to measure people, but also
to define what is a human and
non human behavior. And for me,
actually, one of the first times
that I realized that was in my
first book, when I published it,
all of the people that I
interviewed, I invited them to
come to a launch event so that I
can interview them. And I sent
them all the same message on
Facebook because I was, frankly,
a bit lazy, and I just changed
their name. And after a while, I
didn't hear from a lot of them.
And I was really offended. I was
like, I interviewed you at least
tell me you know, yes or no or
something. And then one of them
who works in the music industry
told me Oh, did you send the
same format of message and I was
like, Yes. And he was like, Oh,
well Facebook then will think
that you are a bot or a spammer
of some kind, and then it will
send your message into the other
folder, which could be you know,
the spam folder or the junk
folder. Because they analyze
your behavior, and this is a,
you know, a sequential activity
and with the same activity,
maybe just change the name. So
that was something that
triggered my my sort of thought
of like how these companies are
making these kind of decisions
of which kind of behavior is
legitimate, and which kind of
behavior is illegitimate, and
then shapes our behavior
accordingly. Because what he
told me that label manager is
that he, of course, has the same
kind of messages, he changes
them in a way that will try to
avoid this kind of being called
spammer. So, this, this was the
sort of analyzing the internet
standards part. Here, I'm
showing you how in the European
Union, when they were trying to
make legislation around the
electronic communication that
was starting to be more popular
at the time. How did they
actually define that? And how
did the advertising industry you
lobbied the European Union? How
did they manage to bypass that?
So what you're looking at now is
the special article from the
electronic director from 2002.
And the way that they define it
is the use of automated calling
and communication system without
human intervention, for the
purposes of direct marketing,
and may only be allowed in
respect of subscriber having
given their prior consent. If
you're European, you probably
know about the prior consent,
I'm going to talk about it, uh,
shortly. But we know that there
are a lot of different kind of
activities, which we consider as
part of that. So for example, if
you remember the horrible spam
attack that we got YouTube, into
YouTube and into our computer
without being asked without our
prior consent. And then, you
know, when Apple was talking
about that, they said, Oh, well,
actually, with article two of
that law, it means that once you
have some kind of connection
with a company, then that makes
it and informed consent, and
then find consent or in turn, or
implicit consent means that if
you have any kind of interaction
with this company, then you are
in a kind of weird relationship
where you can, you you are
allowed to send these people
these kind of marketing
things. And during the end of
the 90s, in the beginning of the
2000s, there were a lot of
debates of whether, you know,
cookies should be legitimized,
and what's happening there. And
this is this is an article that
I really liked from 2001, on the
left hand side, where the
chairman of the United Kingdom
says, cookies have been branded
as spyware tools, or some kind
of subversive software. But it's
what we use every day. And I
think it's quite telling that
this is 20 years ago, where even
then people understood that you
do cookies, and pixels, and all
these things are basically
spyware, and doing this kind of
surveillance over our everyday
activities. But the kind of
normalization that it happened
throughout the years, I think,
is something that we need to
remember that happened with the
kind of the lobbying of the
advertising industry, that
managed to make it seem as if
it's nice and friendly, even
with the name when you think
about cookies. Um, so actually,
according to the law, both
cookies and spam are the exact
same thing, because both of them
are sent through automated
systems. They are meant for
direct marketing, and they are
sent without our prior consent.
But it was really important for
the advertising industry to make
a difference between legitimate
advertising practices, and
illegitimate advertising
practices in order to
standardize what was starting to
be the online data broker online
ecosystem that we know today. So
part of what we understand and
we know today is the real time
bidding, which is happening in
the back end of our screens. And
we don't know about it, because
as I said, before the
advertising industry lobbied for
us not to understand what's
happening again. And basically
Facebook and a lot of these
companies, including Google,
they basically took this
standard of real time bidding
and developed it into their own
different kind of systems. So
when I was talking before about
these kind of what I was talking
about, why should we use sound
concepts is exactly these kind
of multiplicities of actors who
listen to us throughout time. So
we have so many companies who
are listening to our behavior in
the back end, it could be
Facebook, it could be Google, it
could be Amazon, it could be you
know, your your government. It
could be different kind of data
brokers that were not aware of
these Companies are then trading
these data without our
understanding or consent. And so
as I said before, this was part
of the politics around that is
to create these kind of
architectures where we don't
really understand what's
happening. And part of the sort
of one of the ways that the sort
of the people who develop the
standard said, Oh, you know,
we're not going to make it
visible, people can still change
the cookie setting in somewhere
in the setting of the browsers.
And this is part of the politics
that I'm talking about arranging
the architecture in a way that
it will be difficult for us to
actually engage in it in a
meaningful way. And I thought it
was quite funny. Because today,
when I wanted to post
a,
sort of advertise this, on my
Facebook, I used a different
kind of browser. And then
Facebook asked me if I want to
accept all cookies. So if you
look at the left hand side, we
have a lot of choice here, we
can either accept all, which
Facebook obviously wants us to
choose because signals in blue.
And then if you want to manage
data settings, you go to the
picture in the in the right
side. And as you can see, the
only way that I can engage with
Facebook is by accepting
cookies, there is literally no
way for me to decline, to
negotiate to say, maybe I want
these cookies, maybe I don't
want those cookies. And for me,
this is this is part of what
what I'm trying to say with my
book is how these kind of
companies structure specific
architecture, where we basically
have one way to experience them.
And Facebook, of course, is not
the only one, we also have
Google and Amazon and all these
companies. But I think it's
really important for us to
understand that we are presented
with one way of experiencing
them. And, and then we don't see
what's actually happening in the
back end. So what you're seeing
here, some of these devices do
not exist anymore delight to
blame, which was connected to
Firefox in the middle. On the
left, you see Privacy Badger,
and on the right is the UK sort
of ad blocker. And what I want
to show here, I don't know if
you managed to see that there
are hundreds of cookies that are
plugged into my device. And this
is I think for me, one of the
most amazing thing was the most
amazing exercises I usually do
with my students of advertising
students who don't even realize
what is happening in the back
end. And once they show them
that out, most of them are quite
shocked. And I think a lot of
them are like, Why Why didn't we
know this before? And how can we
do something different. And I
think, for me, this is, again,
part of the bigger politics
where our computer screen or our
you know, phone screen creates
this kind of divide of power
relations, where in the front
end, we get a very kind of
pristine architecture and
interface where we can engage
with these platforms, if you're
living in the EU, you might get
all of the choice of pressing, I
accept I agree or okay. But then
in the back end, we have a whole
other online market that is
trading us in milliseconds. And
so this kind of the boundary of
our screen is not only with,
with what's happening in terms
of it's a division of what is
human what is non human also,
because what's happening in the
backend is something we can't
even comprehend. So once we
upload a certain web page, or
Facebook, this these kind of the
trading and the bidding on our
profiles happens within
milliseconds. So our screen
creates this kind of estimate
the boundary of the symmetric
power, that these kind of big
technology companies or the data
brokers have all this. So and
this is, what happens is that
these kind of ads keep on
chasing us. And this is I really
recommend you to see a South
Park, they had a thing in the 19
season where they were
criticizing online ads and sort
of how it's kind of chases you.
And from my research that I'm
doing these days, where we try
to sort of understand people's
that illiteracy is one of the
things that we keep on getting
from people is that not only do
people don't really understand
what's happening with their
data, a lot of the time when
they're expressing these kind of
concerns and fears from
advertisements is that they keep
on seeing the same ads and in a
certain amount of time they say
okay, then after I'm seeing it
so many times, I'm going to
press that ad just so it will
leave me alone. So I think what
we're seeing here is these kind
of ordering of the architecture
and what we kind of can engage
with in a specific time in
space, and how that basically
shapes our behavior. And this
can also be in the shape of how
different kinds of colors push
us different kinds of
disinformation and
misinformation. So I think only
now we start to get this kind of
critical debates of how Facebook
keeps on, you know, pushing
different kind of problematic
material, but actually pushing
problematic material from
Facebook as part of their
business model, because the more
emotional material will be on
their platform, the more that
you will engage. So it doesn't,
it doesn't matter to them, if
it's a picture of your family in
an awkward position, or if it's
disinformation, or conspiracy
theories, because it's all part
of fueling more engagement and
more comments between people.
So I'm gonna push more towards
what's happening these days. And
sort of to show you that today
activists are pushing and I
think that there is this kind of
reckoning of this kind of power
relation and what these
companies are doing. We're
seeing the FTC wants to start
investigating real time bidding
these days. Actually, I think
last week, or or a week and a
half ago, activists show that
the whole consent framework is
actually flawed of the ad
tracking industry. So we are
starting to see a lot of
changes. But the main problem is
that the way that we experienced
the internet today is that these
companies want us to feel that
this is the only way that we can
experience these platforms, it
can only be through, you know,
my own profile that you know,
not many people, for example,
can use one profile, or that it
could only be with cookies, or
it could only be true, you know,
this kind of ongoing
surveillance. And so for me, one
of the main things about sort of
peeling off these kind of layers
of politics and how these
companies have lobbied and tried
to create these kind of
architectures, is to show that
actually, all of these things
weren't strategies that were
ongoing by these companies. So
that also means that we can also
build, you know, different kind
of platforms, and different kind
of things in a different way.
But in order to do that, and
this is sort of relates to what
I'm working on now, is that
people actually are not aware of
what is happening in the back
end. And as I said, this was a
planned strategy. But people do
not understand the political
economy of the internet. So they
don't know most people do not
know that Google and Facebook
are funded by mostly that they
main income comes from
advertising. Most people don't
understand how algorithms
profiling, you know, web
cookies, most people don't
understand how they work. I can
even say further that I'm doing
for this month. And when we ask
people even what is the basic
thing like what is data? What is
the thing that you know, that
these companies may be know
about you and things like that,
most of these people have no
idea. So I think that in order
to to create a change in order
to understand what is happening,
and even more, so in order to
demand a different kind of
future, we actually need to go
to the basics and actually
explain to people what is
happening. And I think
unfortunately, a lot of people
have seen the social dilemma.
And you know, keep on texting me
and saying oh, you should see
that even my mom sent me a home
only now I realize what's really
happening, which is good and
bad, because obviously that
documentary could have been much
better. And I have a whole
Twitter rant, if you want to see
that about that. But um, I think
what it actually shows is that
the way that we communicate that
whether scholars or journalists
or activists, we kind of assume
that people know about these
things. And a lot of the time we
kind of talk from a very sort of
top down kind of approach. And I
feel that we actually need to go
to the basics and actually
explain to people what is
happening in order for them to
demand different kind of
platforms, and to understand
what are the consequences of
that. So I actually wanted to
show you part of that. And this
is part of the research that I'm
doing right now, where we ask
people on the left hand side,
you see how much do you agree
that people that companies would
use your personal information to
personalize your experience. And
you can see your according to
different kind of groups, more
or less, they don't really
agree, but some of them do. But
when we actually asked them, if
they accept the companies would
use their personal information
to track their behavior over
time. You can see here
unanimously that most people
don't agree with that. And the
fact that people don't make
these kind of connections to
personalization and tracking
over time is the same kind of
thing is actually a clear sort
of evidence that shows that
people actually have no idea
what's happening. And they don't
make these kind of connections.
So when you don't know what's
happening, you can't really
demand that you will have a
different kind of future. And
while I believe that, you know,
as academics, a lot of us are
doing really important work in
sort of advancing the debate, we
actually need to, to go to the
basics and to to make people
understand. So I'm going to
switch that. And I'm gonna, I
think, go straight to the end
and say that deviant media
categories are about the
struggles to determine what is
human, what is normal, and what
is social is about what makes us
as individuals in society is
about the default settings of
our lives. And if we want to
change the default settings of
our lives, or at least to have
several options of default
settings, then we need to sort
of peel off these kind of
strategies that were constructed
throughout time to make these
divisions of what is deviant and
what is not. So I think I even
managed to finish before time,
because I was talking really
fast. So there you go.
I'm gonna stop sharing. Great,
Scot Osterweil: thank you very
much. That was fascinating.
Let's see whether right off
whether we have any questions. I
don't see a handout. I guess one
of the things I'll start with a
question, which is, I know some
of your work, you looked at sort
of practices, sort of outside of
norms? Are you seeing media
practice? Are you seeing
communities of attempting to
sort of circumvent these systems
in their media practice? In many
interesting ways.
Elinor Carmi: I think that, um,
a while ago, I saw that several
teenagers are using the same
Instagram account, in order to
bypass different kind of
profiling. And I know that a lot
of activists are also doing
stuff around that. But I think,
you know, there's a lot of
different kind of people who are
trying to object in other ways.
So we have mushrooms, for
example, who is an activist
who's trying to change things
from the legal aspect, which I
think is quite important,
crucial, because, you know, you
need to have several kind of
battles going on the same time.
I think people are also trying
to create different kind of
alternatives to Facebook and,
you know, and Twitter. I don't
know how, how effective it is.
But I also obviously, don't
think that there is only one
way, if we want to change the
way that things are, I think
that we need to go through
multiple directions. So I think,
you know, on the one hand,
having more sort of different
kind of education and data
literacy program, is one way,
another way is to try and change
the legal frameworks that we
have today, which are completely
not equipped to combat these
kind of companies. We I don't
know, if you saw a couple of
days ago that ethic FTC is gonna
have a huge anti trust against
Google, which is great, but what
is it actually going to do? Is
it actually tackling the main
issue, which is the business
model? No, it's the thing oh,
maybe we'll you know, dissect
Google into even smaller pieces.
And also, as you can see, all of
these sort of measurements are
coming after a really long time,
which these companies already
managed to cement themselves as
a huge, an inseparable part from
our lives. So for me, one of the
main things is that actually, we
need to have more public spaces,
which could potentially come
from a government funding, it
could come from maybe having an
internet tax, or different kind
of things like that, where we
will have
other options than the big
companies.
Unknown: It's not a perfect
solution, like any kind of
solution, but you know, it could
be a start rather than counting
on Google or Facebook to to do
everything that we need
basically, today.
Elinor Carmi: I hope it answered
the question
Scot Osterweil: is Emily, did
you? Um,
Emily Grandjean: yeah, I so I
have to admit, I've only watched
I think about half of the social
dilemma. Um, but I'm just
curious to know if you had the
platform of moviemaking to
spread your message, how would
you have changed the way the
message with people about these
things? So if you could, like
recreate the social delimma your
own terms, what would you have
wanted to depict?
Elinor Carmi: I'm happy that
you're asking that Emily,
because I'm just planning to
actually submit to Netflix. So
if Netflix is watching this, I'm
open to get all of the funding
that you want to give me. But
No, but seriously, I am. I
thought about that. I think one
of the main issue for me in that
documentary is is several
things. First of all, asking the
tech bros to answer the the
problems that the tech bros have
created, for me is a huge issue.
There is there are a lot of
smart people both in academia,
both underground, you know,
activists have been dealing with
these things for for years, who
haven't been asked. And another
thing is that, although I like
the US, and I think a lot of
amazing things are happening in
the US, these companies are
global. So if we keep on, you
know, only focusing on the US
issue, it's our recreates the
problem, right? Because a lot of
the standards of these
companies, when we think about
content, moderation, a lot of
the laws that sort of govern
that comes from a us focus and
us centered mindset. And I think
it's quite important to have
different kind of perspective of
how these kind of companies
shape, I would definitely also
focus on Chinese companies, and
Weibo, and different kind of
things like that. And also show,
I think, more historical
perspective. But I think that,
yeah, I would definitely also
not do it a one film
documentary, because I think if
you're trying to show so many
things in one program, that sort
of means that you're losing a
lot of things. So I am thinking
of doing a series. And, um,
yeah, and just to consult with
people who have been dealing
with it in different parts of
the world, and to get them a
richer understanding of how
these technologies affect
different kind of communities,
different kind of regions, and
not to necessarily assume that
all of the people who actually
created a problem can actually
have a more insights than people
who have been dealing with it in
different kind of ways and
aspects. Um, that would be my
approach. And again, that's
links if you want to, I'm
available on email.
Unknown: And yeah,
Emily Grandjean: thanks. If you
need any petitioners for the
series, let me know. I will know
I'm serious. I was actually a DM
him a lot of people this week
saying I can't stand having all
of this, these documentaries and
having my mom telling me Oh, did
you see the social dilemma? It's
so important, I learned so much.
And I was like, Yes, mom. But
so, you know, I think this is
part of
Elinor Carmi: something that I
think the academics need to be,
we need to communicate more,
because I think there's a lot of
really important and great work
that's happening in academia,
but a lot of the time, it's
really difficult for us to
communicate it. So I think that
we need to have better routes to
communicate stuff, you know, a
lot of the things that are
happening with Facebook, we've
been talking about them for a
decade, if not even more, right.
And everybody's keeps on being
surprised every time and
actually. Um, so that means that
basically, we need a better
communication channel between
journalism and way to
communicate with, you know,
everyday people in order for
them to relate with what we're
talking about.
Scot Osterweil: Other quiet
Vivek
Vivek Bald: Thank you, Elinor,
for really great talk. That taps
into all of my, like, existing
paranoia. And, and, you know,
having been involved I was
involved in, like web 1.0,
really in the 1990s as HTML,
coder. Right. And so that I know
that all these conversations,
all these concerns have been
there ever since the beginning?
Right. Yeah. But that the but
that they haven't been, as
you're saying about the social
dilemma, that, you know, these
voices have not been listened
to? And the people who are in
that film knew all of this, too.
I mean, they're, you know,
because it was it was all there.
Right. Yeah. But my my question
is actually about it goes to
some of the work that you've
been doing, the interview based
research that you've been doing.
And you showed us one slide with
people, whether they are okay
with their information being
trapped in these different Yeah.
And, and I guess, you know, part
of what I'm curious about is
whether you're also approaching
those questions in terms of, of
trade off and and what people
are willing to trade off and I'm
thinking about this, in terms of
the really, you know, draconian
Surveillance that that followed
9/11 right and, and for those
who were in the communities
being surveilled, it was a
horrific moment. And and, you
know continues to be so because
it kind of shifted the way that
that, that the state is allowed
to surveil different
communities. But for a lot of
people who are not part of the
surveilled communities, it was
this question of trade off,
well, if I'm safer, I don't mind
if, if I'm being tracked, and
surveilled, because I know that
I'm not the person who's being
targeted, right. And so
actually, this is for my own
benefit. And so in the case of
the logic of the logic that has
been sold about cookies and
other kinds of tracking devices,
is that, you know, this is for
your own good, so that we can,
you know, we can give you serve
to you the kinds of things that
you want to see the kinds of
products you want to buy, etc.
And it's just a matter of, you
know, you just have to trade off
a certain amount of privacy for
this benefit. And so I'm just
wondering about, like how that
plays into, or has played into
the kinds of conversations or
interviews that you've done with
people.
Emily Grandjean: I think it's
really interesting what you're
saying here, and I had a focus
group, actually, today, and a
lot of people said that, you
know, that they were concerned
about different kind of privacy
related issues, but then with,
you know, the pandemic
happening, they didn't really
feel that they have a choice.
And I think that the the non
choice factor here is is quite
huge. Because a lot of services
that we have today are digital,
there's actually very few
services today that you can do
non digitally. So there's
actually not really a choice
here, you're not really being
asked if you can or cannot do
things. And what a lot of these
companies did, they basically
changed the nature of this kind
of contract with people. Right?
So you have these different kind
of Terms of Use, or different
kind of contracts, basically,
where they say, what are they
going to do with your data, I'm
probably one of the few people
will actually read these terms
of use when I can not always
because I tried to have a life.
And you know, that sort of
creates I'm against, again,
these kind of astrometric power
relations, because what are you
actually trading? Do you
actually know what you're
trading? And I think a lot of
the time, you know, we're being
told that we should feel safe,
or you know, that this is okay.
But actually, it's not only to
sell you different kind of data,
and we can't, it's really
difficult to trust these kind of
companies. Because as time goes
on, you realize that actually,
you know, I found that I'm
giving my data just to get to
the Guardian, but actually, I
give it to the Guardian, and I
give it to a lot of other data
brokers who maybe are then going
to sell me a problematic maybe
life insurance or different
kinds of things like that, or
maybe it can harm different kind
of, you know, job opportunities,
or things that we actually can't
really understand predict right
now. Because one of the problems
is that this data, as I said,
with process listening, one of
the main things that I wanted to
emphasize with that is that it's
an ongoing process. So I
actually have no idea who has my
data, how much time Are they
going to keep it? How are they
going to use it for how long and
different kind of things like
that. So I agree with you that,
you know, if it was in a fair
world, or in the previous world,
when we knew that we're making
this kind of a transaction or
kind of a way to say, Okay, I'm
just gonna give you a bit of my
data. And then you're gonna do
it with that. But actually, one
of the things that I'm trying to
argue in the in the book is that
there's actually no negotiation
here, right? Like, you have one
way as you saw with Facebook, I
can only press accepts all or I
accept, and why actually, can't
we negotiate? Why can't I
negotiate individually with each
of the platforms? What do we
want to do? Why can't they have
a bar on the side that I can see
which kind of date is going on?
And believe me that I'm not
gonna get confused, because I'm
sure that all of you, at this
moment have at least 20 tabs
open with like a bazillion other
things happening? So I think
that, you know, we need to think
about these things differently.
And I agree with you that while
some people think that, you
know, it's great, I'm gonna get
personalized, you know, I'm
gonna get, you know, maybe a gym
that I always wanted to buy and
Kislyak you get, like really
good ads, but I can't even know
what is the the trade off here,
because it's so opaque to me. I
have no idea what's happening in
the back end. I have no idea who
is involved. And that is what's
troubling to me. And what's
troubling to a lot of activists
and scholars is that this kind
of like this kind of a scream.
Basically separates between me
and all of the other companies
that can listen to my behavior.
So while I do agree with you,
sometimes the trade off is is
okay. The that sort of the all
the possibilities that it could
be misused or abused is is very
high. And so we need to both
think about how we're going to
regulate these companies, but
also how we create a fairer kind
of trade off here, actually,
maybe I do want to negotiate
with you just like I wouldn't
have an open ended contract with
my landlord, who maybe tomorrow
decide that they want to crush
in my place in the living room.
So these are the kind of things
that I'm thinking about. I hope
that answered. Yeah, thanks.
Vivek Bald: And I agree with
you. On my question was more
about the, you know, how do we
change a kind of broad
acceptance? You know, among, you
know, as part of part of the,
the activist work? Yeah, you
know, how how to change a kind
of, or create a broad
consciousness, that the trade
off is no trade off.
Elinor Carmi: I think one of the
So again, it's about data
literacies. And it's about,
about these very basic things,
unfortunately, the way that
media and computers are being
taught, we're not really being
taught about basic things like
the online economy, what are
cookies, and what are all of
these kind of things. And part
of the project that I'm working
on now, which you saw before,
which was the survey that we
conducted, and now we're doing
focus groups, is to create
these, it's called me my big
data, it's newfields Foundation
funded, and part of the things
we're trying to do is to try to
understand how different kinds
of groups, what do they actually
understand? And then how can we
design education material that
actually is tailored to
different kinds of people. What
we saw with the the survey, at
least, is that people's data
literacies are very much
influenced by education, and
socio economic condition. So the
more educated you are, and the
richer you are, the more you
know, what's happening with your
data. And the more you know, for
example, about privacy settings
and what to do there. So again,
we're seeing this kind of that
how these kind of platforms that
this architecture actually harms
the people who are the most
marginalized. So the answer is
data literacies. In a nutshell.
Scot Osterweil: Um, we have a
couple questions and or comments
in the chat, but I can read
them. But I'd rather if people
ask between the chat and the
q&a,
or the chat as to from the
panelists, and the QA is just
from the attendees. But so I
wanted to, and I want to get to
all of the but I wanted to first
give people an option, rather
than have them out loud. Abby,
did you want to make your
statement yourself before I read
it? Or what's your preference
there?
Abby Sun: I'm sorry, I have just
done an entire day full of
zooms. So I apologize for my
video being off. I'm happy to
read my statement. Also turn it
into a question actually,
because I sort of wrote it.
Elinor before you said that you
would love to make a documentary
for Netflix yourself. So I'm
always curious. I mean,
Elinor Carmi: I think big.
Abby Sun: Yes, it's all the rage
these days in my own background
is in documentary film. And I
think a lot about the politics
of exhibition and all of that.
So for me, what I wrote was, I'm
very off rephrase it to I'm
pretty much I'm pretty
concerned, honestly, as someone
that comes from a film
distribution, exhibition
background, about the platform
streaming platforms, such as
Netflix, that the social dilemma
is on. And for me, the the way
that these platforms are
designed are similar to the ways
that social media platforms keep
viewers engaged. And so for me,
the fact that a film like the
social dilemma, which is
criticizing the sort of, you
know, decisions that these
social media platforms make to
keep viewers uncritically
engaged are in fact, the same
strategies that Netflix itself
uses. So if a film or docu
series even though I do have not
seen the social dilemma, because
I have major problems with the
filmmakers other work he uses a
lot of I think advertising and
marketing strategies and his
work etc. Stand to anyway, don't
need to get into that. So my
question is, anything that's
kind of critical of this type of
the results of these types of
technological apparatuses, how
they as you describe it, like
filter and sort people's
behaviors. I guess I'm curious
for you to talk about your
thoughts of whether or not
anything critical of these
things can be truly critical. If
it's being used also as a piece
of content by these systems,
Elinor Carmi: I think thanks for
your question. I think
it's a really important one. And
I think it is really difficult
to create content that would
resonate, I can tell you from my
experience, um, I remember one
time, I was teaching my students
cookies and everything. And one
day, I saw all of my students
come and cover the camera, you
know, the laptop camera. Yes,
literally everything that I'm
teaching them comes through. And
now they've said, and then I
asked them, so why did you cover
that the camera and all of them
said, Oh, we saw that episode on
Black Mirror, where, you know,
he's, you know, being
photographed. And I was like,
Okay, okay, maybe it's like,
halfway. But I think things like
Black Mirror things, like
stories, basically, stories that
we can relate to, I think are
and I'm sure as the documentary
is, you know, the value and the
power of stories, I think that
could be our way to, to
communicate these kind of
things, clear, and hopefully to
to make critique in an engaging
and meaningful way for people's
everyday life, because I think,
sometimes critique, um, when we
talk about it, and when we tried
to communicate it, it's
sometimes you know, everyday
people maybe wouldn't be
interested, or they don't really
understand how it relates to
them. So I think if we can
translate a lot of our ideas to
do these kind of stories that
people can relate to, that can
help sort of a communicating the
critique in in a meaningful way.
I hope that that answered your
question.
Scot Osterweil: Thank, Abby.
Tarleton, would you like to?
Yeah, I mean, again, and ask
your question. Thank you.
Tarleton Gillespie: Yeah, I'd be
happy to. Hi. Hey, Elinor. I'm
so glad that you made it to
Boston, even if it was only a
little No. Right. So but
yeah, of course, of course. So
this is fascinating here, I was
hoping that you would close the
circle on the talk by coming
back to your use of sound
metaphors. Because I find, you
know, the argument about, you
know, having to sort of
stabilize what counted as cookie
stabilized what counted as a
human user versus non human.
That'll, that's all very
convincing To me, the turn to
digital literacy, for sort of,
you know, what do people not
know, that? They don't know? So,
in that argument, where did your
turn to sound to help you notice
something make a case that you
couldn't have other watches?
Elinor Carmi: Um, I think that
because so thanks for the
question. I think when I started
the research, I the first case
study is with Bell Telephone,
and it's with actual noise and
sound. And so when I was
starting the research looking at
spam, I was trying to think,
okay, Spam is this kind of
disturbance. And so what's
actually happening there, and I
was trying to see, so who
actually created the first sort
of communication model, and
that's Romeo, a to bell. And,
um, and I think that sort of
helped me to think about the way
that the more we listen to
different kind of things, but
also, the more that we can
listen to multiple spaces at the
same time, that creates this
kind of symmetric power. And so
when I'm talking about cookies,
or when I'm talking about
Facebook, Facebook has the most
power by being able to listen to
my behavior, both on the
platform, both outside platform,
at the same time, I can't listen
to my own body, because which
body I consider to be in my
computer, it could be my laptop,
it could mean my phone. Because
of this, as I said before, this
kind of screen, which doesn't
really allow me to understand
who is listening to me. So to
me, listening enables us to
cross boundaries of time and
space. And that means that I can
listen to your behavior when
you're on Facebook, when you're
on Google. And it's an ongoing
process. Which for me, we don't,
we can't really, it can really
happen when we're thinking about
its true vision, because vision
for me is very much constrained
within time and space. But I can
only be in a specific time in
space. And that creates for me,
a singular layer if it may. And
what I realized with Facebook
and all of these kind of
companies that are listening to
us is these kind of
multiplicities of layers and as
as we as you obviously know I
work also on content moderation,
which we had a very great
article that came today on
internet policy review, if you
want to see from my our AOAR
panel in 2019. And there I
examine content moderators and
how they listen. And so I
noticed with that Content
moderators, which at the time
that I was examining it, it was
kind of sort of new, it was 2015
2014. But I was starting to
engage with that I was actually
single, actually, there's so
many different kinds of
entities, whether human or if
it's funded moderators, or non
human like cookies, or listening
to our behavior. And therefore,
there are these kind of multiple
spaces, which I think vision
doesn't really allow us to
understand these kind of
multiplicities. And for me, the
multiplicities are important
because they show us how so many
organizations are involved in
creating these kind of profiles.
And again, this doesn't only
happen in a digital environment,
it also happens as I show with
the bill telephone, in an analog
environment. So when I was
comparing content, moderators to
telephone operators, who also
listened on the line and work,
you know, part of the
communication channel, this is
part of, you know, what I was
trying to engage? No, I hope it
answered,
Tarleton Gillespie: yeah, yeah.
I like that. It's somehow it's
sometimes about looking at
actual listening practices. And
sometimes it's the kind of kind
of metaphor that you use to
train yourself to notice things.
I think that's, I think both of
those are really interesting.
Thank you. Thank you.
Elinor Carmi: Yeah, I think
like, for me, again, it's a it's
kind of an exercise I don't, I
don't mean that we need to sort
of abandon everything that is
visual and optic, I just think
that there is there are more and
more scholars who are pushing
towards thinking about media
through different kinds of
senses. There is David
fairyseason, amazing book about
the archeology of touch. And so
I think that as scholars, and
what I really like about this
department specifically, as I
know, there's a lot of artists
that people are thinking
critically, I think that it just
opens more, you know, spaces for
us to think about what what's
actually happening. So it
doesn't mean that we need to
completely abandoned vision for
all the people like vision
related concepts, but it's just
another way to examine different
kind of media phenomenon.
Scot Osterweil: Tomás, are you
would you like it?
Tomás Guarna: I'm just gonna
read what I said. Because I know
it's so I'm falling on the idea
of distortions? Have you
considered this scenario of
algorithmic listening to bots?
So the algorithm listening to
bots, who will algorithm
algorithmic behavior. So I
wonder what happens to that
feedback loop and how the global
glory algorithm becomes is
sorted by the input of
algorithms. And I wonder what
the consequences are spillovers
for for human use for human
users.
Elinor Carmi: So what is the
disruption of when algorithms?
Can you repeat that?
Tomás Guarna: I'm wondering you
the so you know, we have
algorithmic listening, right?
Well, we also have already
called content production. We
talked about bots, we talked
about how this algorithms
produce content. So I'm
interested in maybe if you
consider that feedback loop,
right, how the algorithm listens
to algorithm co production, what
happens with that scenario?
Elinor Carmi: Um, I think that
what's really important for me,
in my research to emphasize that
it's never only machines
involved or bots involved,
there's always humans in every
part of the process. So you
know, even with platforms only,
when we think about it, only the
recent years, Facebook has
actually confessed that there
are content moderators at the
beginning, they said, Oh, we
don't know what you're talking
about. And then when, you know,
people started pushing, more and
more people started to talk
about that, you realize that
there are people at all of the
all of the points of automation,
it's never a full automation,
there's always humans there. So
I think that when you're talking
about that, this kind of
algorithmic content and also our
Gareth, Nick ordering, they're
always people at different
points of the communication
channel that are going to decide
what is deviant. So sort of what
is relevant for our business
model, and what is not relevant
for our business model, and
hence, will be filtered out. So
to me, that is, it's really
important. And it's really
important for me not to talk
about algorithms in an abstract
way, because then we're sort of
taking away the responsibility
of the humans that are always
involved in that process, and
the politics of the different
kind of humans, whether they're
programmers or the CEOs, or if
they are the more inferior
humans in this process, which
are the content moderators, or
you know, even in Google, they
have, you know, the rankers who
are deciding how things are
going to get ranked on the
Google search results. So to me,
what I think what you're asking,
involves, again, with this kind
of different kinds of decisions
made by humans, and it's never
going to be a perfect kind of
all entanglement but I think
that the way they're going to
respond to each other is very
much related to these kind of
decisions. I hope that answer.
Thank you.
Scot Osterweil: We've got two
questions from the q&a, and I'll
read them out loud just so that
they get into the recording. The
first is from Roku. And the idea
of surveillance and data
capitalism that is being put
forward by the tech giants
nowadays, drives me to always
think of Gramsci and his theory
of hedge emoni following Gramsci
strategies of changing the
systems, he advocated of people
going into institutions, such as
schools, government offices, to
change them from within, would
that be possible in the tech
industry? Would those change
makers be immediately perceived
as deviant and thrown away? And
then ads? I'm sorry, a long
question, but I'd love this
talking about very enthusiastic.
So
Elinor Carmi: no, it's
fantastic. Please, please ask,
and it's great. I really liked
the questions here. It's great
that people engage with the
book. So you're basically asking
if it's the matrix, and if Neo
needs to be part of the system
or not. Um, I think that again,
in order to change the way
things are, I think that we need
to think about it not as like
the one solution, but as
multiple solutions. And of
course, different kind of
solutions are going to be more
relevant in different kind of
regions. So what will be more
beneficial in Europe is not
going to be more beneficial in
the US, or Russia or Asia,
China, Israel, different kind of
places. Um, I do think that a
lot of people are trying to
change, both from within and
outside. I think that we need to
have these kind of forces in all
of the directions. I think that
at the moment, the kind of
instruments that we have, as I
said, before, you know,
everybody had so many hopes with
the GDPR if you aren't following
and I really recommend it to
follow my friends who's an
activist has been trying to
change a lot of things. And he
has changed a lot of things.
What he showed is that even
though we have the GDPR, the
kind of the DPA, the the Data
Protection Authority in
different kind of countries in
Europe, actually provide very
little money to actually take
care of all of the People's sort
of lawsuits against different
kind of companies that are
dealing with their data. So, um,
I do think that people need to
integrate, both in government,
hopefully also in technology
companies, but also that we need
to educate people. So to me,
it's it's multi layered both to
change laws, you have data
literacies that change the way
that technology companies are
operating, and also to change
the way that we are talking
about these things, whether it's
with, you know, more
entertaining content, but also
journalists. So, yeah, it's a
multi, multi year multi step
strategy.
Scot Osterweil: To some degree
with that answer. You may have
answered the following question.
But of this from Hamidreza
Nasiri, what you said about
social dilemma? Isn't that
actually one of the main issues
that are the sources that give
the illusion of informing
people, but they systematically
nor the systemic problems that
make sure that the discourse
remains shaped by the powerful
institutions, the same thing
that Professor balls mentioned,
regarding convincing people that
it's for their own security, or
recently convincing people that
censorship by the big by big
tech is actually in the interest
of the people hacking, one fight
that kind of informing that
persuades people to act against
their own interests, will make
them think that they're actually
engaging in resistance?
Elinor Carmi: Or intense
questions. Um, I, again, I don't
have all the solutions, I only
think that the way to make
people engaged is actually to
inform them. And I think that
people only, um, I have a friend
who's been an activist for many
years, and he told me that the
things that sort of motivates
people to go to the streets is
when things hit you the most. So
in Israel at the moment, people
are demonstrating for the past
few months against Benjamin
Netanyahu and his regime. And
it's not that they haven't been
demonstrating before. But I
think that with the COVID, and
the pandemic, they realize what
they can lose it. I think that
this kind of what it touches
your life, when you actually
know what you can lose, then
people are more engaged. I don't
know if people saw that.
Students here had a whole
demonstration against the
algorithm. So the story was that
students were supposed to sort
of graduate the high school
here. They weren't supposed to
have an exam, but because of
COVID, of course, they couldn't
have the exam. And then the
government designed the weird
kind of algorithms. It made a
lot of mistakes, which meant
that people who came from
deprived areas received lower
grades than they should have.
And then students came and
started to post this and said,
You know, we're having these
different kind of signs, you
know, like, Fuck the algorithm
and going to the streets, and,
and during a lot of petitions
and like asking and attacking
the government, and the
government actually caved and
change these results. So why did
these students didn't protest?
For example, when it was Brexit?
Which is a question that I was
asking quite a lot. And I think
that one of the things is that
with the algorithm, you can
actually see what's happening to
you, it was very visible, right,
you can actually see how it's
going to harm you. With with
Brexit, we don't even know what
is the current what what are the
agreements, right. So I think
that if we actually want to
engage people, if we want to
motivate people, to make the
make these kind of different
kind of changes, we need to help
them understand how that can
actually harm their everyday
life. And that I think engages
people into action.
And we have different kinds of
examples like these.
Scot Osterweil: You know, it's
funny, I follow that from a
distance, and I kept thinking,
it's great that they're
protesting, but shouldn't they
be protesting the whole system
to begin with the one that
orders and sorts them? You know,
in general, rather than just
when it gets it wrong, so But
Elinor Carmi: no, totally. And
also, not only when it comes to
their grades, right. But again,
if you don't really understand
how that affects your life, you,
I think it's harder to make
these kind of different kind of
imaginations on people. And also
people, you know, we show how
these kind of algorithms impact
different kind of, you know,
communities of color, things
like that, but not all of the
people are, first of all,
encounter all of these things,
not everybody here, or really
understand how that can actually
influence you in the future. So,
um, yeah, I think they saw
another
Scot Osterweil: Yes, Srushti had
a question.
Srushti Kamat: Hi, Elinor, thank
you for that. It was great.
I actually have a question about
the assumption that most people
have agency over things like
public demonstration, right? So
I'm talking about spaces in
countries where protesting is
not an option, you cannot go out
on the streets where
digitization is the only way for
you to actually act in
resistance, it kind of goes back
to the question in the q&a, it's
like, if the digital is the only
space you can exist to express
your freedom, express yourself,
then you don't really have much
of a choice. And so how do you
change the narrative of data
literacy? away from cultures
like the US and UK as well,
maybe where you can go out and
protest to societies where you
just can't do that?
Elinor Carmi: I think it's a
really good question. And I
think that, yeah, we have a lot
of assumptions in the way that
in the kind of solutions that I
was talking about, as well, and
this is why I said that there is
no one solution, different kind
of regions will have to respond
in their own way. I do think
that, you know, there are a lot
of demonstrations in other
regions, which are not a sort of
West based and they are doing it
with different kind of means
such as means in different kind
of ways. I think it's going to
be difficult. And I think it's
it's I don't really know, the
exact way, but I think that
different kind of communities
have always invented creative
ways to objects, and to protest
the way that things are
happening.
And
they will have to use different
kinds of tools that are
available. I hope that answered.
Yeah, but I think we definitely
can't assume that people always
have agency. And obviously,
providing people with data
literacy doesn't necessarily
mean that all of them are going
to go to the streets. Because if
you're poor, and if you don't
have the time or money to go to
the streets, then you're not
going to do that. So of course,
I'm not saying this, this, you
know, the one bullet point and
you know, it's gonna free
everybody and we're gonna burn
the streets. And you know, but I
think that it is a gradual
evolution of these things. And
just like, you know, feminism
and anti racist, you know,
groups hot, it's an ongoing
process, right? We keep we need
to keep on fighting, and it
sounds like everybody has the
time or resources to do that.
But I think the more knowledge
that we will have, of what we
can actually do and what kind of
power we have when we come
together. I think that we can
change it, but I Of course, not
everybody will be able to
participate in these
demonstrations.
Scot Osterweil: Great, um, it
looks like unless you have
another question, it looks like
we wrapped, we're wrapping up
right on time. And so I want to
thank you again. And thank you
for waiting for hanging in there
and showing up when you finally
could was really, really
fascinating talk. And I'm glad
that we were able to have it. So
I want to thank everyone else
for who came and look forward to
Elinor Carmi: having me and
again, I just want to remind you
that the book is open access, so
feel free to check it out and
also the playlist and I'm on
Twitter. So if you feel like
continuing the discussion, then
feel free to either DM me or
email me. And it was a real
pleasure during this event,
because you had amazing
questions that really made me
think as well, which is quite
rare. So thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thanks.